[Musik]
gleich morgens schon besser informiert
mit dem faz früh denkern es ist mittwoch
der sechste april
einen schönen guten morgen an sie alle
heute kümmern wir uns hier um die nato
außenminister beraten in brüssel über
ihr vorgehen die eu bereitet weitere
sanktionen gegen russland vor die
impfpflicht ab 60 könnte kommen und
bayern münchen spielt in villarreal dass
ihr kam heute nacht über die faz ticker
corona infizierte sollen künftig doch
nicht selbst über eine isolation
entscheiden dürfen
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
will die am montag verkündete änderung
wieder zurücknehmen das us militär
spricht sich für die einrichtung
permanenter us stützpunkte in den
osteuropäischen nato staaten aus
russland lehnt das strikt ab nach dem
ende der ausgangssperre in lima haben
sich demonstranten und polizisten in der
peruanischen hauptstadt schwere
auseinandersetzungen geliefert
aufgebrachte menschen drängen in den
sitz des obersten gerichtshofs ein
die texte heute kommt von daniel [ __ ]
mein name ist jan malte andresen einen
schönen guten morgen nochmal
der krieg in der ukraine gerade in die
entscheidende phase sagt
nato-generalsekretär ergänzt ortenberg
vor dem zusammentreffen der
nato-außenminister heute in brüssel und
er macht klar wo seine prioritäten
liegen die verbündeten sollten waffen
liefern statt darüber öffentlich zu
diskutieren das sei in diesem
zeitfenster extrem wichtig und es
sollten hochwertig thema sein allerdings
ist die allianz bei diesem thema in
einer schwierigen lage sie will sich
offiziell aus dem krieg heraus halten
ist aber zugleich die plattform auf der
sich die verbündeten absprechen die
briten wurden deutlicher als deutenberg
leistungsfähigere luft und küsten
verteidigungssysteme solle die ukraine
erhalten mit artillerie und anti
artillerie fähigkeiten gepanzerten und
geschützten fahrzeugen das geht deutlich
darüber hinaus was er den ersten wochen
geliefert worden war erstmals soll kiew
nun auch schwere waffen bekommen und
solche die sich für gegenangriffe
einsetzen lassen dazu passen ja auch die
andeutungen der deutschen
außenministerin die wir gestern früh
schon gehört haben wir schauen uns daher
jetzt auch systeme an die wir bisher
nicht geliefert haben cdu chef friedrich
merz fordert die bundesregierung auf der
ukraine alle von ihr gewünschten
waffentypen zu liefern die lieferung von
waffen macht deutschland nicht zum
kombattanten sagt der
unionsfraktionschef
wie wirkt russische kriegspropaganda die
gräuel in butter werden von russland
weiter geleugnet von 410 bestätigten
opfern von massakern berichten
allerdings korrespondenten dazu sei mit
vierstelligen zahlen erschossener
zivilisten zu rechnen es gibt
filmaufnahmen tonaufnahmen grausame
bilder
augenzeugenberichte
reporter sind vor ort von den agenturen
reuters lpa fb von spiegel bbc cnn
auch die faz hat ein redakteurin
botschaft vor ort sie alle machen sich
ein bild von der schrecklichen lage sie
sprechen mit den menschen und es gibt
satellitenbilder die sich mit den
berichten decken besser kann eine
informationslage kaum sein und doch sagt
der russische un-botschafter war sie
lebensjahr auf einer pressekonferenz in
new york zu den verbrechen der
russischen soldaten in butter zitat das
ist nicht der fall das war nicht der
fall und das wird nie der fall sein
zitat ende er wiederholt das mantra des
kreml es handle sich um eine
abscheuliche provokation des regimes in
kiew das russische staatsfernsehen
spricht von einer inszenierung mit
schauspielern widersprüche und konfusion
erzeugen ist ein muster russischer
kriegsopfer ganter vom ersten tag an und
in der vorbereitung des krieges so was
sie führt gipfelt im satz des
ukrainischen botschaft dass in
deutschland andrej melik alle russen
sind feinde für die ukraine im moment
andrej melik beschreibt im interview mit
der faz wie tief die gräben zwischen
russen und ukrainern seiner ansicht nach
sind das ganze gespräch mit ihm im faz
podcast für deutschland
heute beraten die eu mitgliedstaaten
über das fünfte sanktionspaket gegen
russland damit soll der druck auf das
land weiter steigen das hat eu
kommissionspräsident in ursula von der
leyen gestern schon mal so begründet
russland für einen grausamen und
rücksichtslosen krieg nicht nur gegen
die tapfere ukrainische armee sondern
auch gegen die zivilbevölkerung des
landes es ist wichtig in diesem
entscheidenden moment den größtmöglichen
druck auf putin und die russische
regierung auszuüben disco show point
umfassender und schärfer sollen die
sanktionen jedenfalls werden so von der
leyen heute sollen die genauen maßnahmen
festgelegt werden vorab geeinigt haben
sich die eu-länder aber schon auf ein
einfuhrverbot für russische kohle damit
werden erstmals russische
energielieferungen vom europäischen
markt ausgeschlossen
allerdings ist das volumen mit vier
milliarden euro gering verglichen mit
100 milliarden für öl und gas die
reaktion russlands auf die sanktion ist
noch nicht ganz klar russlands präsident
wladimir putin nannte verstaatlichungen
von russischen werten im ausland
jedenfalls ein zweischneidiges schwert
damit nahm er bezug auf die
treuhandschaft und die das
deutschlandgeschäft des russischen
gaskonzerns gazprom gestellt wurde putin
erklärte man müsse ein auge auf
agrarexporte an sogenannte unfreundliche
länder haben
in sachen impfpflicht zeichnet sich kurz
vor der abstimmung im bundestag morgen
ein kompromiss ab bisher ging es ja um
die frage im pflicht ab 18 oder 50
jahren doch nun scheint der kompromiss
eine andere zahl zu ergeben die beiden
abgeordneten gruppen der ampelkoalition
die jeweils eigene gesetzentwürfe
eingebracht haben einigten sich auf
einen gemeinsamen vorschlag einer
impfpflicht zunächst für menschen ab 60
jahren beginnend im oktober im juni
sollen die abgeordneten den beschluss
noch mal revidieren können sollte die
impfrate sich bis dahin ausreichend
erhöht haben derzeit haben 89 prozent
der altersgruppe die ersten beiden
impfungen erhalten 79 prozent eine
auffrischungsimpfung ob der vorschlag
morgen eine mehrheit im bundestag findet
ist offen ein teil der fdp abgeordneten
ist gegen eine impfpflicht die
cdu/csu-fraktion will erst ein impf
register einführen die mehrheit der
ampel koalition wackelt daher
in frankreich tritt die
präsidentschaftswahl in die
entscheidende phase am sonntag gehen
zwölf kandidaten in die erste runde
bezeichnend von den beiden früheren
klassischen präsidenten parteien aus dem
sozialistischen und dem konservativen
lager ist kein kandidat unter den
aussichtsreichsten vier dafür zwei die
als ziemlich weit rechts gelten in der
mitte präsident makro und links der 70
jahre alte jean luc mélenchon
der versucht daraus einen taktischen
vorteil zu ziehen er sieht sich als
volkstribun und sei der einzige kandidat
der hinken mit aussicht auf die
stichwahl und für die rechte lippen
verhindern wolle der müsse eben ihn
wählen derzeit führt makro alle umfragen
an aber eben nur mit rund 28 prozent
kommt meist auf gut 20 prozent wähler
auf etwa 15 bis 17
tatsächlich hat sich mit seinem
redetalent und einem professionell
organisierten wahlkampf den rang des
aussichtsreichsten kandidaten der linken
eifrig erkämpft er tourt durchs ganze
land lässt seine kundgebung als
hologramm auf bühnen in etliche andere
französische städte projizieren er hat
bücher über das deutsche gift
geschrieben warnt aktuell vor dem
bundeswehr sondervermögen von 100
milliarden euro als gefahr für den
frieden in europa er will die nato
verlassen und durch andere allianzen wie
die bolivarische allianz für amerika
ersetzen die einst von fidel castro
begründet wurde ob die franzosen so
jemanden wirklich gerne im
präsidentenpalast sehen würden wer
ausschau jedenfalls sonst sich im image
der albtraum der französischen eliten zu
sein
1400 euro so viel geld bekommt jeder
beschäftigte der chemie und
pharmaindustrie nun als einmalzahlung
eine brückenlösung wie die gewerkschaft
und arbeitgeber betonen erst im oktober
soll dann über einen richtigen
tarifvertrag mit längerer laufzeit
verhandelt werden aktuell war die lage
den arbeitgebern zu unsicher angesichts
des krieges in der ukraine und ihrer
hohen abhängigkeit von russischem gas
eine entscheidung vielleicht mit
signalwirkung wie die chemiebranche so
könnten auch andere tarifparteien
verfahren angesichts hoher inflation
lieferengpässen krieg und
rezessionsangst ist die lage
unübersichtlich wie lange nicht mehr die
pauschale besänftigt die mitarbeiter die
aktuell unter hohen energiepreisen
echten und sie gibt den arbeitgebern
finanzielle flexibilität würden sie sich
doch keine langfristigen
tarifsteigerungen auf
und auch das ist heute das viertelfinale
der champions league mit dabei
eigentlich nur top mannschaften und
villarreal eine mannschaft aus der
spanischen provinz momentan nur siebter
in der liga aber julia nagelsmann ist
ein sehr sehr sehr erfahrene mannschaft
mit den meisten pro kopf la liga spielen
in ganz spanien haben mein trainer der
natürlich sehr erfahren ist auf
internationaler ebene gerade was die
euroleague betrifft noch mal eine
spielerisch erfahrene mannschaft die
definitiv erst mal zu knacken erscheint
wird ich bin trotzdem ganz guter dinge
dass wir uns am ende durchsetzen können
sagte der bayern trainer seine
mannschaft spielt heute gegen villarreal
um 21 uhr geht's los
[Musik]
so haben wir den mittwoch begonnen auf
faz.net gibt es jede menge was er sich
heute zu lesen lohnt falls ihr die zeit
dafür haben zum beispiel hier in der
politik es gibt kritik am wegfall der
isolations pflicht im feuilleton wo
gaming eine religion ist und in der
wirtschaft kein fieber medikament mehr
in russlands apotheken mein name ist jan
malte andresen ich wünsche ihnen einen
erfolgreichen mittwoch wenn sie mögen
können wir uns morgen früh wieder bis
dahin tschüss
[Musik]